young
jx in the building after a big comeback
win
jeffrey before we get to this game
you how's the field to lost to the
lowest rated player who was playing
poorly and then bounce back and be the
number two player on the planet yeah it
is
it's a bit of a shock for me to be
honest because
i had a very bad feeling after yesterday
and coming into today to to be honest i
didn't have much ambition
so you know i just i didn't prepare too
much just played um
knight f3 g3 and see
what happens and uh
yeah i mean i feel very lucky because
especially considering how the opening
went i felt i didn't really uh
have any
i didn't really deserve to it to win
he did seem like he came after you all
guns blazing let's take a look on the
screen at this position when he played
the move a5
oh did you feel like okay the guy thinks
he's got to beat me even with the black
pieces
no i think he was actually just playing
uh what he thought was objectively best
i think the a5 a4 inclusion i feel like
is
is good for
black in general so
i tried to improvise with bishop g5
knight c1 but i think it's not a very
good idea um because
yeah in the game i think it's already
just worse for me
and yeah this position was supposed to
be not so great you had to play bishop
f3 that must have been
not a move you wanted to do
uh yeah bishop through to some knight g4
the good thing is um
it's a very bad bishop so i want to
trade it with bishop g4 so maybe it's
not
such a useless move
but yeah i think
the critical mistake from him was when
he played g5
because i think it just really wasn't
necessary and it created
kind of a hook for me later when i
played h4
but were you surprised by his decision
playing the move bishop e6 given your
given that he had this bishop
sort of good bishop that he didn't have
to give up yeah that's a fair point but
i think i i wasn't actually that
surprised yeah he can definitely keep
the bishops but like i said if instead
of g5 if he just castles i think it's a
very pleasant position for black he just
wants to um
play like rook c8 in 97 and eventually
i'm going to have to
play very passively to hold the c2 pawn
later
this night of yours that went all the
way to c1 made this march all the way to
d5 that must have given you some comfort
when you put the knight on d5 were you
shocked by his choice of knight to d8
yeah yeah that i was definitely well not
at first i mean it made sense that he
wants to bring to d6 but when i saw
knight before was available then i was
wondering what he had uh
prepared there because yeah once the
knight lands on d5
it seems very dangerous for him
you then traded on g5 and in this moment
uh we had a possible move if you took on
b5 here
but i'm gonna prod you and say you have
a winning move right now were you told
before or do you
uh i i mean
my first instinct was probably knight
takes d4 but i couldn't make that one
work so
ah
that was my first instinct as well
jeffrey as it turns out
wow
that's very nice
oh
yeah that's
that was the move uh that you you you've
missed
i it's a gorgeous move we would have had
you we would have called security on
you you can see moves like that right
and knight h4 was was winning on the
spot it turns out
somehow you got yourself to this
position had
did did you realize how strong a move
rook a6 was not at first but yeah once i
mean
once i figured out rook af1 uh rook d8
was fine for him i needed to look for
something else right and uh
yeah i always have ideas of you know 92
94
but i think rook a6 is just a great um
inclusion because
like
maybe the idea is to provoke king g7
rook a7
he has to go king jay back and now
knight d2 is already very powerful that
was exactly what uh alejandro
thought as well that this would end up
freezing uh you completely however we
can back up because there was something
that that you'd ask me the question that
the engine did spot after rook a6
and that is rook takes d3
yeah we were discussing this line um so
rook g6 change center f6
and then e4
yeah yeah i think he
he probably felt that this uh was
enough for a job but under time pressure
he couldn't work it out so
i think we were saying uh rook f7
rook f7 knight g5
rook f7 shack rook f7 knight g5
and then you might have to be precise
with where you put probably g7 makes the
most sense
g7 just to avoid uh because i don't
think i'd take with real quick
right so yeah once i take with the
knight there aren't any checks
and then yeah i guess you can just go e3
e3
wow
temporary sham
sacrifice of a piece
some nice nice things
jeffrey
congratulations seriously that was a
very very very big scalp
and
what are you going to do on your rest
day
i think the idea was to uh to watch
uh moneyball so i will watch that uh
maybe tonight maybe tomorrow but who
came up with that idea
uh it was yeah i
saw this movie was available on netflix
and then i wanted to find a good time to
watch it and i
made it i decided the best time was
maybe uh
tonight so during the sim field cup
makes sense
well congratulations jeffrey huge result
there what a shake-up in the standings
yes